Her low freak bitches. So, um,
you saw the UFC this weekend.
Do you see where I fucked up?
And I interviewed Daniel Cormay after he
had been knocked out. Yep. Dude, here's,
here's something that's like, people
think that somehow or another, uh,
the UFC told me not to do that and
I did it. Nobody said anything.
It was just a hundred percent my fuck up.
And it was also my idea in the first
place to stop interviewing fighters after
they'd been knocked out.
It was 100% my idea. No,
it happened before in championship fights.
It happened often, right? Almost always.
Whether a guy got knocked out or Tko
or submitted or loss of decision,
I would interview the winner and I
would interview the loser every time.
Every time. Okay. So it's more
or less they ran out of the cage,
which has happened before. Yeah, I get it.
So you're just on running on instincts
here. This is what happened. Um,
I was there for Gonzaga versus cro
cop. Remember Gonzaga head kick, Cro,
cop, and just fucking into
a Bolivian and it was bad.
And I interviewed Cro Cop afterwards.
And I'm telling you,
that dude had no idea what I was talking
about. And I remember saying to the,
to the production team at
the time, it was like, man,
I don't think we should interview guys
after they get knocked out like that.
Like that was my, my saying
like that. And then, um,
the one time it happened again is with
ouster and after when Alistair Overeem
floods deep a meal chicken,
he remembered this gay team
that didn't really happen.
You remembered a Steve Bay tapping rather.
And it didn't really happen.
I was like, this poor guy. Like he's,
he really has this memory in his head
and it's just not correct cause he just
got knocked the fuck out.
He got knocked unconscious on television,
like completely flat line.
And then a few minutes later I'm
asking him to be coherent. I'm like,
I don't think it's fair.
So it was my idea to stop
doing this and the UFC agreed.
So it's not like, like they said, we've
got to stop doing it and I violated.
I violated my own idea
and I just did it on,
this is what happened after the
fight was over. First of all,
the fight was crazy shocking how violent
the ending was because John Really did
fucking hate Daniel and Daniel I think
really did hate John or at least had real
anger. There was real emotions with these
guys. It was insane. It was intense.
When John landed that fucking head kick
and you saw him moving in for the kill
and then he,
he stopped him right in front of us.
He got on top of him and just blasted him.
It was like right there.
I remember looking over and I'm like,
Jesus,
he was just dropping tell on real
close to, it was pretty close.
If I remember correctly. I want to
say it was like right off to my right.
If I remember correctly. You had a good
look at it. I had a real good look at it.
Yeah, I mean obviously I'm cage side.
I've got a good look at everything,
but I had a real good look at that.
It was intense. It was intense,
and it was also, I felt like there
was a couple shots, too many.
So I remember being
stunned like, Oh, I'm a,
I'm a big fan of John Jones,
but I'm also a big fan of Daniel
and I'm a fan of both of them.
I know they don't like each other,
but I like both of them.
I liked them independently and it just,
I can't help the fact their enemies,
but I love hanging out with John
and I love hanging out with Daniel.
I love doing commentary with Daniel.
I love that guy.
So I would never do anything to
make him look bad. I just got,
I was in shock.
There was,
he was confused because he got knocked
out so he was confused that that why the
fight was stopped and said he was mad
that they stopped the fight because he
just didn't understand
because he just been chaos.
So he was arguing with big John.
I didn't hear the exact words
then he was arguing with Dana.
I didn't hear the exact words that
either, but Dana was in front of me. It's,
you've got to realize when a Kale like
that happens in a world championship
fight and you're standing in the octagon,
you're surrounded by all these
people screaming and cheering,
the the fucking noise is so loud.
It's hard to figure out
what the fuck is happening.
So I couldn't figure out what Daniel
and Dana were arguing about, but Dane,
his whole head was red. He was like,
he was like, that fight was amazing.
He fought your heart out.
Like I couldn't tell exactly what he said,
like you'd hold your head up high. It
was a great fight, that kind of stuff.
But I think Daniel was still trying to
figure out why the fight was stopped
because it just had happened.
He'd just woken up.
Then he realized he got head kicked and
then he was really sad and then he was
upset and I went to go talk to him and
literally as I'm going to talk to him,
he's turning to me and I have
the microphone. I'm like,
why am I interviewing him?
After he got knocked out,
what the fuck is wrong with me?
I don't even realize what I was doing.
I was just in shock,
almost like I went on instinct
and I'm interviewing him.
If I had a chance to stop and think
I should have been like, oh yeah,
he's been Kao don't do it. So in the
middle of me even talking to him,
I say I normally,
I don't like to interview fighters
after they've been knocked out,
but it's just like I was stuck.
I was already there talking to him and I
didn't want to leave and walk away from
him and I really do care
about that guy a great deal.
And I just watched him get
knocked out and now watch him.
His heart's pouring out and he's crying.
You know,
when he was realizing that he got
knocked out and he lost the fight,
it was all awful. And um, so I put a Po,
it was haunting me all night.
This is, nobody had said anything.
Nobody from the UFC got mad at me.
No one said anything to me.
There was just me thinking, why did I
do that? Like why did I interview them?
I shouldn't have interviewed him even
though we used to do it for every fight.
Um, it was the right move to stop doing
it. And ironically it was my idea.
It was my move.
I don't even know if other guy,
I don't know if Brian's stands still
interviews guys after they've been knocked
out.
I don't think he does though,
because Brian Actually said thank you to
me for that because he got interviewed
after he got knocked out by
Vandelay and he remembers thinking,
I don't remember what happened.
He didn't know what the fuck happened
and they were interviewing him.
He's trying to keep it together for the
interview. And he was like, you're right.
It's not fair.
It's not fair to interview a fighter
after they've been knocked out.
I just fucked up man. There's no
other way to say it. I just, uh,
if I could go back,
I definitely would have taken it back.
I definitely wouldn't have interviewed
him cause feel, uh, feel like he didn't.
And he sent me a text message saying it's
all good. I didn't say anything crazy,
so it's no big deal. But you know, he
could have, you know, he could've said,
I never got stopped. I could
have said, you know, he could,
you don't think anything,
like if somebody doesn't explain
to him well enough what happened?
And then it takes a few
seconds and you forget again.
That's the other thing about guys had
been knocked out like you like say if,
if I got knocked out and I asked you
Eddie, what happened? And you said, oh,
this dude just punch you in your jaw and
knocked you out. I'd be like, no way.
Hey Man,
what happened?
Like a few seconds later he started
asking again when you get knocked out,
it's real weird. So, um, it's a
huge fuck up on my part, but it was,
I was in shock, honestly.
It was so ferocious.
The final barrage was so ferocious
and it was the way it was.
The Way John did it when you heard him,
once he knew he heard them,
he just started going after him. And one
of the, the spookiest things that he did.
Was he the, he tripped him. You see what?
He tripped him like Daniel's like sort
of stumbling back and John just sort of
scoops his leg out from under him a trip.
Some Daniel falls back and John just
moves in on him and you could tell Daniel
just couldn't get his feet back under
him and John just jumped on him and just
marked them.
Carme did great on his feet
for awhile there. He did great.
But I was really impressed
with John John Stryker to dude,
he throws so much unorthodox shit.
Those stomps on the knees do,
that's high level shit and the
volume is thrown a lot of strikes.
That's his shit. He was in
tremendous shape. Taste on those uh,
those elbows from, you know, from left
field, you know right down the pipe.
Yeah. He's doing a lot of elbows, man.
And he's throwing all kinds of shit.
He's throws everything for kicks. There
was a lot of front kick right to the,
yeah,
those a front snap kicks throws those
old kicks to die and hyperextends your
knee. Love that close
to him. I love that. Oh,
I hope he keeps going because
he's evolving so much as a strike.
I hope he gets more like,
I hope we get to get to gather 100%
you never seen him arrested again?
No more bullshit. No one cares about that.
I do. I want him to get arrested again.
It's like he tore his ACL.
What's the gift will be back.
He's going to be back you. It
doesn't matter. Let them party.
He's the king of the world.
He's the,
he's the probably the best fighter
of all time. Let them do some coke.
Let them party data should be getting
some house. You know what I mean?
Fuck it. He gets fucked up. Hey,
that's, that's actually better press.
So what he needs is like,
it's, she should take,
you should fake Duis and drunk and
stoned just like they do in TMZ.
He just needs a constant security
detail to keep everything away from him.
I let him let him do whatever he wants.
He's the king of the fucking world.
And you don't want him getting locked up.
We lost a whole year of them and
then we lost a year before that.
You don't want him to get
Tyson that that's for sure.
He could get locked up for five years.
That shit happens to people want
what you want them to do is have fun,
but don't do anything illegal.
Don't let him drive us,
can take his keys stolen to do
anything illegal. Just how sturdy team.
Have a rubber party room.
Go off and just say, dude, you go off
for five hours, whatever you want.
Boom, but you can't leave this room.
Do you ever been to one of them?
A bouncy warehouses?
We can go from one trampoline to the
next champion and those are amazing.
We go all the time and my son all the
time, those are the best man. The best.
So anyway, um, even though
I already talked to Daniel,
I felt like I put it on Twitter.
I apologize on Instagram and I was like,
I gotta apologize in the podcast too.
Job
[inaudible].